what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest crazy happenings in
the boruto story
some huge developments were introduced
in this chapter including ones that a
lot of og naruto fans
might find intriguing so definitely make
sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy seeing these boruto
reviews and want to keep them coming
chill the hokage within and smash that
like button until it changes colors
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
naruto and boruto videos
before we get into it a quick thank you
to private internet access for
sponsoring this video
private internet access has over 30
million downloads and it prides itself
on being the world's most transparent
vpn provider
with 100 open source software they never
record or store the data of their users
and because it changes your ip address
and reroutes
your internet traffic through an
encrypted tunnel private internet access
hides your online activity from your
internet service provider
network administrator and government
sensors
one of my biggest pet peeves is paying
full price for a streaming service like
netflix but then finding out that i
can't enjoy a lot of content just
because i live in a different country
thankfully private internet access works
with all major streaming services
so you have access to all of your
favorite content anywhere in the world
in addition to helping to safeguard your
online privacy
private internet access blocks ads
trackers
and malicious websites private internet
access is available for all platforms
there's a 30-day money-back guarantee
and they have a dedicated team of
customer support experts available
24 7. so go through my link to support
my channel and get pia vpn for less than
three dollars a month
and two extra months for free that means
only
two dollars and eight cents per month
and 83
off now without further ado let's jump
into it spoilers and all
this chapter starts off with showing off
some claw marks which are pretty much
code's version of minato's flying rigen
except not as cool because you gotta
leave these giant patterns all over the
place
he can travel from mark to mark
instantaneously though it's explained
that this is how he's getting to where
the ten tails is and it's also implied
that you can't simply remove the marks
because they have people watching them
rather than destroying them
as always i love shikamaru and while the
others suspect that he could pop up
anywhere
and watching all places and searching
for others is clearly the best solution
chikamoto the japanese chess master
understands that all four of these could
be bluffs that are just causing them to
spread their forces too thin
props to code for being strategic with
this kind of psychological warfare he
not only has these set up in konoha but
around other villages as well as
shikimaru points out this one dude is
exhausting all five villages
pretty crazy feat we jump to kawaki on
hokage mount rushmore looking down at
the village and you see some ninja
people
chilling probably they're monitoring him
and this isn't surprising because we
were told that boruto sasuke naruto and
a motto as well
would probably be monitored since
they're all along with kawaki supposed
to be code's targets
but there may also be a layer of people
not trusting kawaki
in particular because he is an outsider
then we meet up with mad scientist amado
and kake who is worried about what he
plans to do with kawaki once he's
restored kawaki's karma
remember the karma could be brought back
just to be used as a weapon without
ishiki being able to come back
according to amado and right now they
definitely need every weapon they could
get
it's pretty hilarious how amado tells
her he's not trying to hide anything and
he has zero intention of doing konoha
wrong but he just doesn't want to
discuss it with her this girl doesn't
give up easily though and now notices a
container and asks about it
again amado asks her to leave but she
keeps questioning him
this container is probably one of the
most intriguing things about this
chapter we know that amado has the
ability to create very strong fighters
so this might actually be a key to
victory or at least the key to some very
interesting things coming about
he assures her that he's doing this to
help kanoha and he's already run it by
katasuke the special weapons droning
and then he straight up tells us that
this one pointing to the container
should be a powerful konoha ally
since we know that we in a sense got the
return of jiraiya through kashin koji
now that amado is in konoha there's no
telling what dna he could
use to create a clone based on a
legendary fighter perhaps hokage of the
past like a god of shinobi may be
amado's scientific abilities have sort
of been like the edo tensei with a twist
in this regard
and the fact that they are building up
the hype so much by keeping it a secret
leads me to believe that we may well see
another fan favorite legendary shinobi
return through a powerful clone that's
just a theory though let me know in the
comments
what you think about who or what is
going to be
in this container for now though we jump
to code who's sort of trying to keep
aida's little brother entertained
it's weird to see this kind of dynamic
from our villains right now
sort of like a weird little family you
definitely can't see an osutuki villain
trying to humor a kid like this
albeit this kid is supposed to be super
powerful this is all making these guys
seem less threatening but hopefully
they're just doing this to subvert our
expectations later by having them be
way more dangerous and ruthless than we
could have expected daemon is definitely
an annoying spoiled kid who has to be
put up with because of his insane power
he jumps and seriously hurts bug poor
bug because he supposedly tries to sneak
off without spending enough time with
daemon
after not seeing him for so long bug
thinks to himself this is why he hates
this kid and i think we're all with you
there bug they definitely do a great job
of making damon hateable and annoying
as code is observing damon's power he
decides to test it out by using his own
from the looks of it daemon's reflection
is instantaneous
and kicks in automatically regardless of
his intent code plays the whole thing
off as if he was just illustrating his
own ability from the start
showing how he can move freely between
his claw marks and that he can move
others back and forth too
as long as it's one at a time of course
bug is a guinea pig for him to
illustrate while bug actually thanks
code for getting him out of that
situation with daemon
code casts the compliments aside saying
he was just checking out the kids
reflection ability
but perhaps even he was annoyed enough
with daemon's behavior to put a stop to
it damon says that code's ability is
neat and he likes it but no one cares
what damon likes so let's move on
coate is trying to get more info he's
clearly being strategic here trying to
learn the limitations of damon's
abilities
but before he can explain ada interrupts
him again a weird development even
though these guys are supposed to be on
the same side here there's clearly
distrust on both sides as
ada tells daemon that he shouldn't
reveal his card so easily
she shuts code's curiosity down by
saying daemon reflects attacks like she
said and that's all code needs to know
for the time being she says more time
needs to pass before she can show him
everything
and code definitely wants to see
everything after this code concludes
that
she must have other abilities she hasn't
demonstrated as well
but she stays mysterious saying wouldn't
that be interesting
again this chapter is more so laying
down the groundwork for the chapters to
come
but i am getting super curious in seeing
the upcoming battle not only do we get
to look forward to seeing all of their
powers in action
we'll probably get to see who's in the
container and what sasuke in our
tokawaki
and boruto are capable of right now in
the meantime kawaki is shopping for
groceries saitama style he definitely is
haunted by this idea that he doesn't
belong here
he's haunted by jigen's words that he's
just being used and there's no place for
him here
even though the naruto family is trying
so hard to make him feel at home
it definitely feels like it's going to
be kawaki's inability to accept their
caring and kindness
that will lead him to the time skip
kawaki that's gone off the rails
whenever characters are able to trust in
others in naruto
they usually can overcome their old
sometimes
evil ways that were brought on by
feelings of loneliness most of the time
we also catch up to boruto who reveals
that he's been taking the biakugan
medicine
poison for a week but there's no change
good or bad
hinata comes in and asks about kawaki
clearly worried because he's never
missed dinner before
again the distancing of kawaki from the
family is being emphasized here
naruto the hokage himself finds kawaki
on hokage mount rushmore he's not happy
to see
that he's having a rice ball in water
for dinner when hinata prepared a real
meal at home
kawaki being a jerk to further try
distancing himself from them
says he's bored of hinata's cooking
which is going too far bro
best girl hinata's cooking is great and
no one is allowed to question it
even naruto is like bro you've licked
the plate every time
because of how good it is and kawaki is
silent clearly caught in his lie
kawaki lets naruto know that he really
likes the spot and the view from it
he likes looking at the village naruto
protects but he reiterates the haunting
belief that there isn't a place for him
anywhere in the village
he's just a troublesome outsider who
wandered into this trouble-free peaceful
place
clearly this dude did not read the
boruto prequel
kawaki goes so far as to say ishiki was
right
not a good sign whenever you find
yourself agreeing with a villain and
then naruto is like alright bro that's
enough and just lifts him
up like hawaiki is not a moody teenager
who's trying to be cool and edgy all the
time
in turn kawki's like hokage bro let me
down while naruto ignores him saying who
cares about ishiki we're going home
and in a heartfelt moment calls kawaki
his stupid son
again he's trying so hard to make kawaki
feel like he belongs
we get a nice warm panel where the
naruto family all welcome him to the
dinner table and naruto reveals that
it's a welcoming party for him
we even got the broken vase that was put
back together a metaphor for kawaki
himself while he wants them to just
throw out the ugly broken vase
himawari refuses saying she chose it and
it's even more precious to her now
kawaki feels that he himself is broken
and that's why he wants them to throw it
away and to abandon him too
he finds it hard to believe that they
could love and accept such a broken
individual
that's why he grabs on to ishiki's idea
that they must be using him or that he's
out of place here
and is only burdening them not actually
bringing any joy to their lives boruto
ends up gifting him a konoha forehead
protector a sign of belonging to the
village
since boruto has sauce case he'll give
him this one or at least loan it to him
until he gets his own as naruto makes a
joke of borto having a good idea for
once everyone laughs
except you see kawaki's dead pants there
he finally tries the forehead protector
on and he feels so awkward he's even
sweating
boruto does not help matters by saying
it doesn't suit him at all
hinata and himawari though are always
super supportive
and they say that it looks great
himawari even suggests keeping it on his
neck since some people do that style
and that is something i enjoy about
daruto even though it doesn't make that
much sense i like how people find
creative ways to wear the forehead
protector even if in some cases it's not
even
serving its name purpose by protecting
the forehead still it looks cool and
that's what's important in shonen manga
shikamatu for instance kept it on his
left arm even boruto after initially
messing with kawaki
says he's sure kawaki will grow into it
as he grows as a shinobi so overall very
heartwarming moment heartwarming
atmosphere here in the naruto house
where pretty much
everyone is open caring and supporting
kawaki later naruto again reiterates
takaoki's family and can stay with them
as long as he wants but mentions that if
kawaki doesn't feel the same way
naruto has failed as hokage he wants
kawaki not to worry they'll find code
and kawaki like everyone else can live
here at ease
or else there's no point of naruto
becoming hokage
and clearly as always naruto is very
ambitious with his goals
he wants to protect everyone and make
them feel like they belong
too since he knows how painful it is to
feel like you don't
very admirable goal but if you guys
checked my every hokage's backstory
explained video link in the description
then you'll know that although hokage is
often mean well
ruling is usually much more complicated
than it would appear at first glance and
it's no surprise that naruto can't
accomplish all his goals and make
everyone feel like they belong all the
time naruto is definitely way too hard
on himself and has super unrealistic
expectations but i guess that's part of
naruto's charm as well and at this point
kawaki has an important decision to make
will he trust in naruto like naruto told
him to will he use the new power in the
form of a karma that's purely a weapon
as a motto advises
or will he do something different
completely well it seems like he picks
option 3. he decides he doesn't need a
karma but there's one thing that he can
do to protect konoha and lord
vii so again it's him actually caring
for everyone that's making him betray
them and their wishes
he was asked to trust in naruto and
others but it seems like that's clearly
not his plan here
he's decided to take matters into his
own hands from the looks of it he feels
like he's the problem in an otherwise
peaceful village so he probably plans to
leave and perhaps even attempt to beat
code or try to get him to spare the
others at least
since code does have naruto sasuke and
borton on his radar too
not just kawaki we'll see kendo for sure
especially with how strong code is
supposed to be especially compared to
kawaki now
he'll definitely have to use more
indirect ways to try to stop code if he
can
just the possibility that jumps up at me
is when kawaki runs into aidan code he
may use ada to beat code since there's
clearly a distrust between ada and code
and since ada wants
kawaki to be her boyfriend that might be
kawaki's ticket to saving everyone will
it actually work out so easily
probably not since this is a shonen and
we want to see strong people fight
without their limiters
so i think code won't be stopped so soon
and we will get the same goal all out
but it's the only plan i could even
picture possibly working right now it's
a good cliffhanger because clearly
kawaki thinks he has a solution and i'm
begging to know what it is
overall not an action-packed chapter
obviously but some potentially very hype
mysteries are introduced and kawaki got
a bunch of characterization and it seems
more and more likely with each passing
chapter that him wanting to protect the
others is causing him to want to
separate himself from them
more and more and that tendency is what
will probably result in his
transformation from naruto's son
and one of the family to estranged
villain maybe it's just me but i did
actually like some of the more mellow
moments here like kawaki at the grocery
store
that was pretty dope for some reason
just seeing konoha in a more downbeat
way but i do hope we get some more
action soon
and since we had a couple of more
downbeat preparatory chapters in a row
i'm expecting the next one to deliver on
some craziness now that the current
villains have been well introduced
along with the container and kawaki
seems to have made a definitive decision
that is clearly not what naruto wanted
as always let me know your thoughts on
this chapter and what you're most
excited to see happening next
if you do enjoy seeing these boruto
reviews and want to keep them coming
channel the hokage within and smash
that like button until it changes colors
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future naruto and boruto videos and
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my growing
naruto slash borto playlist which
includes videos about all the otosuki
all the uzumaki all the kage and much
more
link to that is in the description and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you